let me ask you a question you think cops
should be able to go up to anybody and
ask him for their ID you think that's
racial profiling or you think that's
something that's okay if you say that's
racist you believe in sanctuary cities
if you say that's why we have cops I
want you to check an ID with somebody
and say hey is this guy up to something
good or bad you're somebody that doesn't
believe in sanctuary cities in America
we have 11 Sanctuary States California
Colorado Connecticut Illinois
Massachusetts Jersey New Mexico New York
Oregon Vermont Washington State and
Washington DC these are Sanctuary States
aside from the 11 states we have 500
cities in America that are Sanctuary
cities a total of 20 million people
living in those cities that's six
percent of our population where they say
we believe in sanctuary cities what is a
sanctuary City the term was first used
in 1980 to describe cities that refuse
to cooperate with Federal governments
immigration and naturalization service
with Federal government's Immigration
and Naturalization Service ins in the
enforcement of immigration laws meaning
they defy the federal law for example in
DC a cop cannot ask somebody hey can I
ask your ID that can be seen as racial
profiling the same applies in many
different cities as Chicago and other
places and the reason why we chose to do
this video on Sanctuary cities because
just over the weekend New York City a
video has been going viral showing 200
immigrants standing around saying hey
New York City hey mayor Adams you said
your Sanctuary City since spring of 2022
you've attracted 93 000 people coming
because you said we'll take you a matter
of fact three percent of all hotel rooms
right now in New York City are being
used for migrants that's 3 500 rooms out
of 125 000 hotel rooms where the
government's paying for it so Sanctuary
cities good idea bad idea what's the
solution we're going to talk about that
today
thank you
so if you get value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel so let's talk about Sanctuary
City so in America when you get pulled
over they arrest you they fingerprint
you the Police Department is supposed to
send that Rapport to the FBI and an FBI
to ice ice can come back to that Police
Department including Sanctuary cities
and say we want you to hold them for 48
more hours because we're going to do our
due diligence Sanctuary cities release
the person and say no you can be left
alone because we're worried because if
we don't do this immigrants will no
longer call the cops because if
immigrants don't want to call the cops
because they're worried ins going to
show up and if they don't call the cops
they're not helping local police
officers to make sure the criminals are
being caught so we can't scare migrants
so that's why we don't check their ideas
because we got to kind of work together
that's kind of how the sales pitch is
right so now let's look at the pros and
cons on how both sides sells the pros
those in favor of sanctuary cities
number one protect undocumented
immigrants from deportation it's kind of
like the thing I was talking to you
about let's not scare these guys number
two they promote Community Trust when
undocumented immigrants feel like they
can trust local law enforcement they are
more likely to cooperate with law
enforcement and Report crimes number
three they are good for the economy
undocumented immigrants often contribute
to the economy by paying taxes and
starting businesses and spending money
in local communities so that's the pros
now let's look at the cons they make it
harder to enforce immigration laws
number two they encourage illegal
immigration some people argue that
Sanctuary cities encourage illegal
immigration as they create a safe haven
for undocumented immigrants number three
they are a waste of taxpayers money some
people argue that Sanctuary cities are a
waste of taxpayers money as they often
require additional resources to
implement and enforce their policies for
example mayor Adams with all the
promises happen guess who he's asking
for money the federal government so let
me get this straight do you live in New
York City maybe you're in La maybe
you're in Miami maybe you're in Fort
Lauderdale maybe you're in Dallas it
doesn't matter you are now responsible
to help support what's going on in New
York City even though that's not where
you live do you see what happens with
taxes so they eventually go to the
federal government to say they need
money matter of fact the top 10
Sanctuary cities Federal funding you
know how much you've been asking for
2.27 billion dollars who pays for that
you and I do let me just give you an
idea about what some people have said
about Sanctuary cities on both sides and
I'll give you some testimonies of what's
happened with some criminals in
sanctuary cities President Biden has
supported Sanctuary cities and has
called on Congress to pass legislation
to protect them mayor Garcetti of La has
said that Sanctuary cities are a matter
of life and death for undocumented
immigrants Senator Bernie Sanders has
said that Sanctuary sitters are moral
imperative and has called on Congress to
pass legislation as well to protect them
now against Sanctuary cities president
Trump has said Sanctuary cities are an
affront to the rule of law and has
threatened to withhold Federal funding
from cities that do not cooperate with
ice attorney general Jeff sessions has
said Sanctuary cities are a threat to
Public Safety and has urged the justice
department to take action against them
and Senator Ted Cruz has said Sanctuary
cities are a Haven for criminals and has
called on Congress to pass legislation
that would defund them now what kind of
crime has been done in this Sanctuary
series let me give you a couple stories
Juan Francisco Lopez Sanchez
undocumented immigrant from Mexico who
was convicted of killing a woman in San
Francisco California in 2015. he was
sentenced to life in prison without the
possibility of parole Luis Barca Montes
is an undocumented immigrant from Mexico
who was convicted of murdering two
police officers in Sacramento California
in 2014 he was sentenced to death and is
currently awaiting execution on March
2022 a man named John messine a citizen
of Haiti an illegal immigrant was taken
into custody for the murder of Terry and
Brenda Altman and charged with two
counts of first-degree murder Antonio
Ulysses Perez a 38 year old illegal
alien from El Salvador accused of rape
after the Oklahoma County Sheriff's
Office failed to honor an ice detainer
and released him from custody so some of
them may be watching this in your fourth
Century cities you may say that's unfair
Pat you're doing exactly what these guys
are doing look at the names you're
reading you know that's racial profiling
that's not fair well we have to look at
Stats and sometimes these stories are
not easy easy stories to look at so then
the next conversation becomes do illegal
immigrants commit more crimes than legal
immigrants and this is what Cato
Institute tells us in 2018 the illegal
immigrant criminal conviction rate was
782 per 100 000 versus legal immigrants
was 535 per 100 000. meanwhile it's 1422
per 100 000 native born Americans so
legal immigrants commit the fewest
crimes in America people who came here
illegally okay then it's illegal
immigrants then it's a native born
people that were born here right those
are the races you're looking now some
people will say well it's not correct
because illegal immigrants you know how
do you attract them they're not
documented so you can't really the
numbers would be higher it's skewed you
can't really do this fine all I'm
telling you is the number so if we ask
the question there's four of us here
we're talking about this stuff we asked
the question Mike says I agree that
illegal immigrants would commit fewer
crimes than Native American Native
Americans because they're afraid of
being sent back to their country so
they're more careful to not do anything
that is an argument that can be made
however these are the numbers when Trump
was President he made November first the
national day of remembrance for
Americans killed by illegal immigrants
you put the number 63 000. this is
something that is concerning to a lot of
people in America in different places to
live so now I got some thoughts on this
that I want you to be thinking about
part number one let's just say you're a
sanctuary City and you're defined
government law government I'm not going
to follow your guidelines but I saw the
this up we're not going to do it because
we're a sanctuary City we want to make
these immigrants feeling comfortable
when they come here but hey you know
we're going to need like 2.27 billion
dollars can you please send us some
money because uh we kind of need your
help to defy your laws but can you
please because we care about immigrants
more than our locals I mean I know it
kind of sounds contradictory but send us
some money please we need your help
right and we're not going to follow your
rules do you see how stupid that sounds
right here's an expert to you
immigration America's Got 51 million
people that are immigrants here you ever
take the number one number one and you
got some of the other countries in
Russia I think Saudi Arabia you got some
of these other countries that are there
great I'm an immigrant I came here
legally I lived in Germany at a refugee
camp for 18 months I remember living
there local Germans didn't like us
because we kind of did cause havoc and
we messed up their culture a little bit
they didn't like us it wasn't like well
we're Germans I'm like well I'm from
Pakistan I'm from Afghanistan I'm from
Czech I'm from Yugoslavia I'm from
Albania I'm from Poland well you know
this is your know you come here and mess
our stuff up and you're getting together
with our daughters and messing up our
culture so that was a little bit
uncomfortable for them right finally I
came to the states and I'm grateful to
be here there's a couple things we have
to be thinking about what's more
important to protect people that are
here or people that want to come here
it's a valid question right who's more
important well of course it's Americans
do our policies protect more Americans
or do they protect more people coming
here well Pat you know you're not being
empathetic you don't understand these
people have a very tough life totally
get it I understand right but you can't
say that and then you say wow why are we
involved in all these wars well these
guys have tough lives but let them solve
their own problems exactly so you can't
say that yet you say let's do this yet
your city's a mess and mayor Adams is
here talking about how they're in a
conflict in New York because the
citizens of New York are not happy
because of what's going on in the city
but he still wants to be a sanctuary
City because you understand how
complicated this is let me give you
another conversation here to be thinking
about do you know what percentage
Americans adopt two to four percent
American parents adapt now would you
adapt I got a question for you would you
adopt
you may say
I think so okay fair you know what
percentage of Americans support adopting
33 percent
but only two to four percent do you know
what percentage Americans are like wow
Sanctuary city is great you support it I
do give us that one bedroom you're not
using well no no no no no no let them go
to somebody else's house but not my
house what happened do you see the leak
and the contradiction and the hypocrisy
and these arguments that eventually when
it comes down to the individual they say
no now why do some people adopt some
people adopt because they can't have
kids some people are that because they
want to give back to the community they
want to get back and contribute some
people adopt because they go to church
and a church is doing a sermon and a
message saying hey there's a lot of kids
that need help here's some stories and
somebody prays they say I want to go
give back and I want to die and some
people say I will only adopt children
that are under the age of two because I
don't want to adopt older kids because
they can affect my kids there's a lot of
different ways to adapt now ask the
question why some people don't want to
adapt well I can't afford it fine number
two I think it's going to mess up our
culture if they come into our house it's
just going to really mess it up and my
kids are doing good I don't want to
confuse them what if this kid that I'm
adopting has drug issues and has seen
stuff and they're going to tell my other
kids and my kids start picking up the
habit I'm a little bit worried these are
all valid conversations that people have
okay very valid conversations but the
idea
of us the way we sell America
I want
me as an immigrant I owe to America I
owe to the founding fathers I am
grateful to America I don't look at and
say what can America give me I look at
what can I give back to this country
because I owe America some politicians
want to say no no America owes these
guys I think we're not making our
priorities in the right place
there's many problems in the world many
of them if we want to solve every single
one of them it'll come at a cost of us
going bankrupt you saw what happened to
our rating Fitch just downgraded us from
a triple A to double A plus this is the
first time since 2011. so we're spending
so much money we're in so much debt
helping everybody else's problems now
our credit cards are maxed out and we're
being downgraded yeah but what what are
you saying we shouldn't send that money
to Ukraine we send more money to Ukraine
last year than Russia has in their
military budget every year we could have
sent that Spend That 70 to 100 billion
dollars in America and how many problems
we could have solved so many of them
cops in schools protection for our kids
there's so many veteran there's so many
things we could have done so many things
we could have done but no we're spending
money because we want to solve
everyone's problems so what's the
message here don't do immigration this
is The Melting Pot pad we shouldn't do
that no I'm grateful that they allowed
me to come to America but to just keep
the door open and say anybody and
everybody forget about the Border you
know you don't believe in that you know
you don't live that way you know you
don't live your door open for anybody to
come in why should America do that do
you see how that sounds ridiculous
that's why Sanctuary City doesn't make
sense to tens of millions of people in
America if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel if you've not seen my
video I did on the DC disaster this is
the city that you can't ask people for
ID because it's Russia profiling wait to
see the stats on DC how much of a mess
it is if you've never seen that click
here to watch it take everybody bye-bye
bye
foreign